i understand i've already said a bad
word because
if there's progress then there has to be
progress toward a goal and that was
i think the word that ex that elicited
the first heckle this morning uh last on
monday morning
uh so uh i'll be talking about progress
toward goals there will be goals
but um
these are not going to be goals that i'm
imputing to nature okay i'm not
suggesting that evolution has a goal
um
there will just be
um goals that i set up from time to time
to analyze various situations so the
first goal i want to talk about uh
is my goal for this talk
um
or at least for the the subject matter
that i'll be talking about in this talk
ultimately i'd like to be able to talk
about quantitative
uh estimates of rates of various
processes
um
uh and the sort of theme of my talk is
you shouldn't necessarily expect
progress to be proportional to time
um
uh
it might have some other functional form
other than just
being uh
proportional to time
on the other hand i don't want to lump
all polynomial rates of growth
into
one class and and
be satisfied
to say that
uh
that they're all equivalent to one
another
and um
uh well at the moment i'm in a math
department i've spent a lot of my life
in computer science departments before
that i've worked both as a mathematician
and an engineer
and um in computer science there's a a
tradition
um
one of the core values is
placing a high value on negative results
um so this is also very common in in
mathematics proving that things cannot
be done
um
is something that seems
uh
harder and therefore more valuable than
proving that something can be done to
show that something can be done you show
how to do it to prove it can't be done
you have to consider all possible ways
in which some clever person might do it
and rule them all out simultaneously so
i'm i'm
a victim of this
uh mindset
as well and so i'd like to to emphasize
uh negative results in this talk
so the first uh one i want to talk about
is
um
a paper by haldane that's already been
mentioned twice in this uh conference
and uh that's the title the cost of
natural selection and it is um the tone
of the paper is
as a negative result it's it he's saying
that um here's a
a problem in the theory of evolution and
we have to somehow come to grips with it
um
uh
and the conclusion he comes to in this
paper is that to fix
each gene in the genome if there are
some genes that you would like
that evolution would like to
uh bring to great prominence or even
complete fixation
then
um it takes about
some number of generations per
substitution and that's
i think the point of the paper is is
that he's asserting that
the the time the number of generations
you have to spend to fix n genes is
somehow proportional to n
okay
um
uh
i
i'm not going here to
uh flog the horse of of haldane there
are many papers that uh point out
um
uh erroneous or or limited assumptions
that he's making uh i want to pick up on
uh
the idea in one of these papers by
maynard smith
um
and it's uh this notion of truncation
um which appeared this morning in
in
manfred's talk
and
um
uh
carry it to what i think is its logical
conclusion and get from it
a lower bound so i don't i don't want
to worry about
you know whether whether
uh
i don't want to stop at pointing out um
as maynard smith did that that holding
is
wrong i want to try and find what is a
valid lower bound on the number of
generations you need to fix in genes
so um
of course to prove anything i'm a
mathematician i'll need to make some
assumptions um so
imagine that you're a farmer um
and
uh so you have a a uh
a population of stock of some sort and
uh you want to fix
um
uh in particular the alleles in
particular loci to be the good thing the
thing that you want to breed them for uh
and they're already present at moderate
amounts uh there's a version of the
theorem that that will apply even if
they're
uh present in very tiny amounts
initially but suppose initially
everything is there half and half there
are two alleles a good one and a bad one
and
the average number of uh
the average population of of each
uh allele is is a half okay
um i'm going to make a number of
assumptions some of which are crucial
and some of which i think are
easily avoided uh i'm going to just for
simplicity assume that's it's a haploid
genome um
uh i'm going to assume no mutation
occurs
um
during the
the the period to which this uh
result will apply so
there are two reasons for this one is i
want to talk about the cost of natural
selection and so i want to
ignore other processes that might be
occurring and i feel entitled to do this
because there's a time period
time scale on which natural selection
has an effect
that's
arguably between
mutations
which occur on a longer time scale
i'll assume non-overlapping generations
i think that's an innocuous assumption
it's what haldane also assumed
so it's a discrete time process
i'll assume sexual reproduction that
will be absolutely essential and we'll
see what happens if we don't have sexual
assumption
reproduction later no assertive mating
um
uh i think that's
uh
in essential
um
no linkage and recombination that will
be absolutely essential if the good
genes are linked to one another then you
if you get one you get both and so
uh you're not going to get
uh
that sort of uh result i'll assume that
the fecundity of this stock is is uh
unaffected by
not only the genes that the farmer is
trying to fix but also by any other
genes that might
inadvertently have their
frequencies altered by the
processes that are
being undergone and now i come to the
the
assumptions about the farmer i'm
assuming the farmer
knows not just the phenotype of the of
each individual in the stock but
actually
the
uh genotype so the farmer sequences each
uh their animals um
and i'll assume that the farmer is
omnipotent in deciding which animals get
to reproduce after he just
decides that
i should have said he or she it used to
be a a program what's my line and a very
frequent thing they had was
uh
a woman who did something like breeding
pigs uh and this was hard for the panel
to guess because they never guessed that
a woman would be breeding things but um
uh so i'm assuming that the the farmer
knows
what the genome of each animal is and
has complete control over whether it
gets to reproduce or not so complete
control over reproductive fitness okay
and survival of course does the farmer
know the fitness of all possible genomes
or energy know he sees he has to test
the fitness of that
um
no the
so the fitness function is the farmer
the farmer is trying to
um
uh
obtain a population of the same size as
the original in which
these in
uh at these end loci
all the genes are good in every uh
member of the population
okay and in order to do that the farmer
gets to
direct the gene effects the gene
interact with each other
the fitness is not additive in the
properties of the genes or
specifically
so
the farmer wants
white tall
okay the pharma has one particular
genome which you like yes yeah
yeah exactly
and he wants the whole population to
have at least at those
in loci exactly what is desired
and i'm assuming that whatever happens
that other loci is not going to
you can make his stock sterile or
something like that
okay so
what i'm assuming then is is that
there's a completely arbitrary
map from the genotype to the phenotype
and a completely arbitrary map from the
phenotype
to
the
ability to survive and reproduce
okay
so of course
this is a very strong assumption
um but we're trying to get a lower bound
so that makes the result all the
stronger
then now i'm totally confused because
the fitness was just determined by the
farmer he has one genotype that he likes
yeah
but now you're saying i have an
arbitrary function for whether it can be
so what i'm saying is the farmer can
behave in an arbitrary weight the farmer
is
the function that determines how the
department can't do it then neither can
evolution yeah all right
limits on the selection that's this
point if the farmer cannot do it
the farmer gets to completely control
which stock breed but how many is there
a minimum number uh oh okay so i'm going
to be assuming a finite but large
population
um
the um well maybe uh maybe i'll discuss
this after i
um describe what the algorithm will be
this will be something we've also seen
this morning um
the pharma will choose a threshold at
each stage for how many genes
on the average are right in the current
sorry
yeah
the farmer will choose a threshold and
will allow only those
uh
stock
that have
that fraction of the genes right
in the farmer's opinion to breed and the
others will not be allowed to breed at
all and so i i'm still totally confused
it seems at one point you said the
farmer had one particular phenotype that
he liked yeah like gene a from here yeah
gene k from here
from there yeah and that's the only one
he cares about he likes that that right
and he doesn't have that at the
beginning right so
then you said the ability to reproduce
all those things or some arbitrary
function
of all the genes
that's the that function describes the
farmer's behavior
but the farmer is is he's caring the
farmer cares about
one particular genotype and everything
else is bad yes
everything is deeply bad
that that's right but he
there may not even be
an element of the population that has
that phenotype so at the first round no
no i understand that but it's not it's
not that okay the farmer can sculpt the
landscape to be as beneficial as
possible to evolution as quickly as
possible to that peak that he wants
right i think it was being said yeah
thank you i think that's okay yeah
okay
okay so the farmer is going to
choose a threshold
and
then truncate the population to those
individuals that are
above the threshold allowing them to
reproduce
um and not allowing any others to
reproduce
and then changes
changes the threshold will change from
step to step
um
and then after of course calling the
the herd the farmer has to let it regrow
to its original size this is exactly
what manfred describes so but if one
guy's perfect has all n genes then the
game is over because you could threshold
it then and
what if one guy is perfect or a small
number is perfect then you let those
populate and then you grow the
population from them and then you're
done well uh
that's that's a strategy and that takes
the number of generations
a number of generations
that goes from you probably need two
things to be perfect one male and one
female um
uh to the size of the original herd and
that will depend logarithmically on the
uh
so the size of the original but you may
not have that that on the average you
won't okay yeah
have that
okay
so this is the basic step you
you
you call your stock
picking out those that are above a
certain threshold in terms of the number
of genes that are good
number of loci at which the gene
is good
um and then you
uh breed until you've
returned to the original size of your
population and then you can repeat this
so for example
uh
at the at the outset you could set your
threshold uh
to be
just uh so so initially if everything is
completely random you have a binomial
distribution it looks like an
exponential of like a normal
and um
so you can say i'll only breed those
that are above average
and uh so then
uh
the average in your new population
the next generation is going to be some
fraction of a standard deviation above
what the average was originally
originally half the genes were good in
your population and after culling and
breeding you've increased the
the average by a computable amount okay
and
this is really the only thing the farmer
can do i mean the farmer is looking at
genotypes and deciding for each animal
which
um
ones to breed um and you you can show
that for a given reduction in
uh for a given number of animals that
you allow to breed you may as well pick
just those that are above a threshold
because any other choice will be
stochastically dominated in terms of the
average level of genes
by
that choice so then it's just a question
of
how many times do you have to raise the
threshold and how much
should you raise it by each
amount and
that depends on the fecundity of
the stock
how much they increase by in a given
generation
but um
uh
this
strategy is essentially optimal at
raising
uh the
uh frequency of each good gene to being
a one minus epsilon after that there's a
little end game
that you have to play where you've got
enough
of the perfect
stock that with a reasonable number of
generations you can
call to just the perfect ones and let
them expand to the size of the original
herd
so
the conclusion you come from to is that
the number of generations you need to
fix n genes
grows as the square root of n and the
the constant depends on the fecundity
as i said before but it's my point is
it's not proportional
to
the number of genes you fix it's
proportional to the square root
um and it's a lower bound you can't
fix n genes in a number of generations
that's logarithmic
in the number of genes you want to fix
there is some limit it's just not a
limit that's proportional to the
population
depends on the population size no i'm
assuming that there's a large finite
population i have to assume it's finite
in order to talk about returning
the population to the original size if i
wasn't required to return the population
to the original size then i could just
uh
uh go along until i i had
some perfect animals and then just quit
there
uh and it's uh it's the constraint that
i returned to the original size that but
also the constraint that you didn't have
every possible combination in the
population origin that's also that that
depends on the population size as well
um
um if you have a big enough population
you have all combinations there
originally
the population is bigger than two to the
little n there yeah but but um
uh
so
the
um
okay so
so suppose the population is large
enough that i have everything there
okay um so um
uh initially everything is present with
frequency a half so if there are n genes
i want to fix
a fraction
two to the minus n
of the population will be these perfect
guys and now to restore that to the
original size i need n doublings of the
size of the population and so i'm using
n steps to do that
so even if
there are some perfect things there
originally that's not the way to go
unless you're lucky and there are lots
of them there yeah
there's a random step and that's the
sexual reproduction
so the sexual reproduction
no the farmer controls which animals get
to reproduce the farmer does not get
it doesn't rule meiosis
does it roll a recombination that's the
crucial thing okay
sorry
that that gives us a
next generation in which there's a
binomial distribution again
on
each each of the at each of the loci
nice so this is an interesting point
about what partners actually do
and actually the optimal strategy is to
control the mating because you have a
kind of in a vinyl population you want
to reduce increase and so the optimal
scratch is slightly better than this if
you
choose the mates so as to avoid
i was asking
if he knew anything about
how important this assumption was and um
uh this is a particularly bad thing you
want to avoid
yeah
no it's about
slowing down lots of variation so you're
losing very challenging challenge
and you want to slow that down so you
want to have a strategy which balances
progress which is
another way of looking at is you want to
fix the deleterious
potentially deleterious genes in a
in a good state and you just add them to
your your end and you say you want to
yeah and i'm assuming the farmer could
see the genes
not just the not just the phenotype yeah
but
by avoiding ingredients
avoiding reducing the variation in the
trait you're looking for which is
another good
but this this uh
this exercise is an exercise in reducing
variation you're you have certain genes
that you want to fix at particular
values and and you don't care by
definition my assumption what happens at
the other cheeks you know in a finite
population you might mix one of the good
ones you might lose one of the good ones
because you were so busy selecting on
other good ones
yes
that's why i'm assuming it's a large
population so that you get good
approximations to the binomial
distribution
so did you say that 50 was the optimal
strategy no no no
no
what what the optimum is will depend
upon fecundity and how many generations
you need to
expression
you know c is going to be a a
complicated expression and
um but c is a complicated question but
the schedule for the threshold is that
complicated
uh at the beginning it's not complicated
um
well it depends upon you see i started
off saying you want to absolutely fix
these n genes uh in practice one is
happy if
uh the
the bad genes are only epsilon and if
they're only epsilon then
depending up exactly on how you measure
that
uh you know what norm you put on the on
the error vector um there will be
different end games
different ways of playing the end game
um so really what i'm talking about
is uh just getting to the stage where
all the errors are very small
and
for getting a lower bound of course you
have to get all the arrows to be very
small before you can get them to be
perfect
on the schedule or even in the early
stages then of what the optimal
truncation is yeah so um
um
uh
you will um
uh in the early stages uh truncate so as
uh
uh to
restore the original
um
uh
population in one generation so you're
making relatively small truncations
um
and um
that's assuming that you're you're
starting from a
a place in the middle uh the process
actually accelerates because even though
the standard deviations are going down
the size of the standard deviation
relative to the number of errors you're
trying to get rid of is actually
increasing
okay
um so
as i've
argued this is actually
a lower bound i i think it's
a lower bound in the sense that that
holden
uh
uh intended his
uh paper to be deriving a lower bound
and my point is just that it's not
proportional to the number of genes it's
proportional to something else um
sex is absolutely essential here because
i'm ignoring mutation
and so the only way you can get perfect
organisms if you don't have
recombination is to have them present in
the original population
that's that's the only source of
randomness here
um and so then
uh it just as in the example we went
through you need a number of generations
proportional to n to amplify the perfect
uh
subpopulation to be the size of the
original population
yeah draw for candidacy though so i i
mean he's totally agrees with like
felsenstein and nay and and and crow on
on the reproductive excess of chicanergy
being the critical part of whole names
load but um
what if it's yours is malthusian right
so there's no density dependence it's as
easy to go from half the population to
full as it is to go from very small to
half yeah i'm assuming there's a
carrying capacity that you wouldn't go
above but then it's you just multiply to
get because like in a real population
not the farmer yeah
you know restoring the second half of
the population is harder than
usually harder than restoring the first
half yeah
um yeah so so then there might be um
uh you might want to initially go to a
very small popular smallers you could
get by
with
um or a third where you're sort of in
the middle of the logistics or somewhere
i mean it could change right yeah
um and then at the very end you would
amplify once
um
to get back to the herd size you wanted
but
yeah i think in fisheries management you
know wildlife management they have sort
of maximum
reproductive access kind of models
my cost measure is the time the number
of generations and i'm not
counting the cost of feed or
anything like that
do you have any
any hints that sometimes it's good to
sort of create small pools and to have
uh breeding within them and then link
them together and make bigger pools or
is everything happening in one
well the farm has complete control yeah
the question is not right well no the
question is fine i mean
yeah i mean you you might
divide the stock into two
classes and
uh try and improve each one separately
and then somehow combine the results
yeah
but this is this is a case where the
effective fitness of the farmer is
putting on
is just additive so some of the effect
additive is the wrong word there you're
adding up the number of genes that are
right and then you're thresholding it no
i agree with you
it's not it's nothing like the additive
small additive effects in that
model no no yeah yes
the quantity which you're taking before
you put this non-linear function on it
is additive yes and that's why it pays
to keep the whole population mixed
together if that quantity was not
additive then it pays the breakup
population in some sort
yeah yeah so it's the ad yeah the payoff
function is
a function of the sum of the individual
contributions
okay um so i mean basically what i'm
doing is i'm taking two sort of
um not absurd but easily criticized
uh
things and trying to improve them
slightly
and make them less
objectionable so the next one i want to
um
to deal with is
uh treatment of evolution as a random
walk and uh this was done by steven j
gould in a book called full house and he
modeled evolution as a random walk on a
line
so
uh what uh think about a species
that's taking a random walk on a line
and the the ordinate that
the species is walking along is some
sort of complexity
um
again i'm not imputing the nature any
uh
uh
goal
uh but you might be interested in more
complex organisms and find them more
interesting than simple organisms and so
we might be interested in
analyzing the origin of complexity
so
the idea is if you're sitting
at that middle dot there you take a walk
to the left that's decreasing complexity
with probability p and you take a walk a
step to the right
at each uh time step with of course with
probability one minus p
you you gain a unit of complexity and um
uh
gould assumed that that the two
um
probabilities were equally balanced okay
so so you're
equally likely to become less complex
through you know forgetting some
uh
evolutionary
improvement or
it turned out not to be an improvement
so you regressed your original state
and you're equally likely to gain a unit
of complexity and
um
of course um so
um
he also pointed out that
there's a limit to how
uncomplicated you can be if you start at
the origin you're going to make a random
walk and so after a number of steps of
time you'll have a binomial distribution
but you're not allowed to
have negative complexity there's a limit
to how little complexity you can have
and still be alive so he said
okay there's a wall at the left and
you're constrained to stay to the right
of it and then of course
what happens is the left half of the
negative part of the
normal distribution wraps over and
uh
essentially doubles the
the
uh
positive part and at some later time you
know the distribution will be like this
but any given time your your
most of your
walkers are within a few standard
deviations of
of the origin um and a few standard
deviations is is
um
uh square standard deviation is
proportional to the square root of the
time
um
uh and so
uh at time t
most of the species will be very simple
they'll be within square root of the of
the origin and he pointed out that this
is observed in practice that you know
most species are
cyanobacteria or very simple one cell
things
and of course there are some walkers
that manage to get very far out but
they're
as a fraction of the number of species
they're very tiny
okay now of course uh this model is uh
highly injectionable because it's
absolutely sensitive to this assumption
that you're equally likely to go in
either direction if you're more slightly
more likely to go to the right than to
the left and the whole population sweeps
out triumphantly to the right
making linear progress with time
okay completely different qualitative
behavior
if there's even slight bias to the left
then
there's a an equilibrium distribution
which is the exponential
uh
uh
you know it's the embedded markov
process and the single server q and uh
the q q length just declines
exponentially
and as time goes to infinity the
whole population
uh approaches that
fixed distribution in the limit in the
other two cases that there's no limiting
distribution everything is
eventually
extremely spread out
so
um
uh
i want to
try and find a modification of this
um
scenario in which uh
there's something like
uh slowness of uh progress
uh that he described but it's not
sensitive to the to the individual
parameters and what i'm using for this
is a random walk in a random environment
so there are two types of randomness
going on here first there will be a
random process that creates an
environment in a random way and then our
species will take a random walk in that
environment and the environment remains
fixed once it's been generated
okay so here's the model for the random
environment uh again it's already been
described today it's going to be the
infinite tree of a branching process
this will be a one species single
species branching process
so you'll be able to we'll be able to
compute the
extinction probability even
with pencil and paper uh the model will
be very simple
um
uh it it's a tree so all i need to
describe uh is the
random variable that's the number of
offspring of a given individual
and so i'll say each individual has two
children with probability a
and no children at all with probability
one minus a
okay
and so the average number of children
will be 2a
if that's
strictly greater than one then
uh with positive probability
uh the population will expand
exponentially um if it's equal if it's
strictly less than one then with
probability one everything dies out and
uh if it's exactly equal to one if a is
a half
then uh that's the critical case and the
probability of dying out is again one
but now it happens
linearly rather than exponentially fast
okay and of course since we want
to be able to talk about large amounts
of progress and not always condition
on the event that
uh
the tree is infinite okay so it doesn't
become extinct
okay uh in the critical case that's
conditioning on an event of probability
zero but it still gives a very
well-defined tree
and in fact what it looks like is
there's a spine
and dangling off each node in the spine
is a little tree which uh
is is is finite
but there's only one path that that goes
down to infinity in this case
so
um
here it is in pictures you're sitting at
the black node
with probability one minus a you have no
children and with probability a you have
two children and drawn your parrot there
too
okay and now after this tree has been
created
uh we come in and make a random walk in
it and so now i again have to have that
parameter p that describes
uh
whether you regress or make progress
now
regressing was going to the left before
now it's going up in the tree because as
a computer scientist with roots of trees
at the top and leaves at the bottom
that's not this isn't
so uh you will ascend with probability p
the same as before you regress with
probability p
uh if you're a
leaf
uh you have no children then you ascend
with probability p and you stay with
probability 1 minus p and
if you have two children
then you go to either of them
with probability
half if you don't descend given you
don't ascend
so there it is in pictures
okay so um
uh gould's case is a equals one
everybody has two children of course now
you get an infinite tree rather than a
line
but um
nothing ever stops you so
um
uh
p in his situation is just the same as p
here it's just that we've turned things
90 degrees and expanded to tree the
level you're on corresponds to how far
you can horizontally in this situation
i found one other
paper in the literature that examines
this model which is due to harry kesten
and um
uh he actually
um
uh studies quite a a large class of
processes but it has an intersection of
one with the situation i'm considering
and that's where
a equals a half so it's the critical
case in generating the tree and it tree
looks like
like this there's a spine a little tree
is dangling off and p equals a third and
what that means is
if you're if you have two children
you're equally likely to go
either of the three possible ways up
left down to the right down to the left
okay and they're all equally likely
that's that's the common theme of all
the things he does
okay but i want to be able to play with
the parameter p and also with the
parameter a uh so that you're no so i
can talk about other things that
correspond to what gold was doing
what you mean to go
to go up this means you move to your
parent
so you you think of it as undoing the
last mutation
or
actually
gould was thinking in terms of
speciation events so you you you decide
that you're not as good as your parent
species and and so you just go extinct
and
that line returns to its parent that
line of descent terminates with you
yeah
why that should be equally likely to
as is going down i don't know but
okay so uh the conclusion that custom
came to
is that at time t most walkers are above
the level
cube root of t so it's even you're even
slower than in google's case i'll point
out later this is a completely different
phenomenon the phenomenon here uh is
what i call trapping when you descend
into one of these
little trees you have to work your way
out and if p is greater than
a third you have a bias downward and so
it takes a lot of time to actually climb
up you know first few steps you go down
downtown it was great and and then you
have to climb out before you
of all of these evolutionary dead ends
before you get to make further progress
um
so
let's sort of switch processes a little
bit the first time i enter the trap
at that point in time i'll throw the
coins that determine what the trap looks
like
okay
and um
uh and and then i'll take the random
amount of number of steps that i need
to enter the trap and come back out
again
that's a random variable that random
number of steps
is finite with probability one
but it has an infinite expectation for
certain values of the parameters like
testings
okay and
these random variables with
their finite with probability one
infinite expectation are often glossed
over in probability courses
um
uh as being pathological they come up
all the time
um if if if we flip a fair coin and you
know i pay you a dollar when
i win and you pay me a dollar when
i win
um suppose the first coin comes up heads
and so i pay you a dollar okay if we go
on flipping eventually we'll get we'll
be even again
sooner or later
we're bound to return to the origin but
the time expected time to do that is
infinite
furthermore if if we play this game
until returning to the origin
um
well if if we play it for n flips some
huge number n and we ask how many times
did we return to the origin it's not
proportional to n it's proportional to
the square root of n
and this is exactly the same sort of
thing during your first visit to a trap
if you regard the trap is also being a
random variable the number of times it's
time steps it's going to take you to
re-emerge and get back to where you can
make progress uh is is going to be one
of these random variables uh that has an
infinite expectation and so to go down a
long distance it will take you know to
go down a distance d it will take
roughly d cubed
time steps because you'll spend all the
time in these traps so i guess the
heuristics would suggest that it's that
you have t to the alpha where alpha is a
function of p
is that or is that the wrong
that that's right it'll be a function of
um
p and a
uh in fact he proved much more than this
he proved that that the random variable
of the amount of progress you've made
divided by p q cube root of t
converges to a to a distribution and i
don't have anything nearly that
precise but i can show that trapping
occurs
if
p is less than a certain threshold which
depends on a
and uh so here you see
um well kestin's
situation is this point okay
and it is another of these knife edges
gould's
point is this point
means you will never get out
it means it will take you a long time to
get out
uh
uh
if if you make these steps of progress
it will take you
um
uh a number of steps more than linear
and d to
if you go to descend d levels
because the expected value is infinite
yeah that that's that's the thing what
to return
to uh the starting state in the coin
flipping game
once i'm down one
i will eventually return
but it'll take
the expected time to return is infinite
and what that means is
to return n times
i'll need n time n squared flips
to see ends n returns to the origin it's
not
that there's a certain amount of time
needed for each
return
yeah that would be infinite
but still you are going to see returns
each
occurring with some frequency the
question is what's the frequency
the rate at which they return it's just
not proportional to n anymore
or proportional to t
so if you're in this
region at the very bottom trapping will
occur and uh to descend these steps
in the tree you will need to take
uh
uh an amount of time that grows as d to
some power greater than one
just to get a biological understanding
of the trapping is it something like if
i'm if i evolve into a whale would they
have to evolve back into i don't know
whatever land animal wales came from in
order to make it no i don't think so
yeah so
so
um
i find it very difficult to get a
completely consistent view of what's
going on here so
um
gould identified a walker with a species
but i don't think the idea is if you
evolve into a whale then you have to
un-evolve but everybody talks about
evolutionary dead ends
so what happens is
that
the offspring species turns out to be
less fit than the parent species
and so
it takes time for the offspring to
stop competing with its parent
and
that slows down the
parent's ability to
evolve so and there is an analogy where
you want to go to species
if you say that the
if you're on a local fitness maximum
and it takes k mutations to get away
from that to get to a higher point you
have to go through a valley and you need
k steps so then the probability of doing
that is loosely speaking mutation rate
to the k
if you ask what is the chances of
finding of getting stuck on a peak which
is has k mutations that you need to do
better than that is also some functions
of some number to the k
then you get exactly this behavior
so it's
okay so um this trapping is completely
different phenomenon
uh well
let me give the quantitative results so
um
as you approach the
uh the bottom line in this picture as
long as you stay away from a being close
to one so that
there are very few dead ends
as if p goes to zero so you have a very
strong forward urge um
the trapping becomes stronger and
stronger i mean with with gould's
phenomenon he was sitting at the knife
edge of p equals a half if he moved even
a little bit
below p things got better a half p
things got better here
as you go below
this top boundary here which starts out
as a
third
we should go below it things get worse
and worse okay so gold is up there
things get
better
things get worse as you go up from here
okay
in this region things get
worse as you go
as you go down and uh the next slide is
just a lower about an upper bound to the
exponent of t
uh of course if you
flip it around you get a lower bound to
the
uh the exponent of
uh the distance okay and so you can see
as long as a is bounded away from one
the numerator is just some
bounded thing
and the denominator
goes to zero under those circumstances
the denominators
is blowing up and it's forcing theta to
be small
it takes longer and longer to make
progress
so
that's just saying
what i just said so thank you
more questions for nick
so i guess there's a comment which i
think
it's a way it makes it even more
interesting if if you ask now i have a
very large population so some
individuals are picking up mutations and
going in directions are going to be dead
ends some may be luckier to pick up
mutations that don't go to dead ends
and then there's a question of what is
the dynamics of this tree and when you
tend to get stuck when you have a very
large population that's competing with
each other
and that i think also can come back from
your earlier question to the earlier
part
is and of course depends on how much
benefit there is for being one level
further up the tree um and there's an
interesting optimization question i
think there if you look at a big
population which is maintaining some
diversity so it doesn't get stuck too
easily
but still eventually going to go up
yeah
so
um
i mean you might try and amalgamate it
into one
single walk in a random environment
where the the walker now represents the
whole biome all species that are
competing with one another and
yeah that's not evidence this is where
this is the dynamically generated
diversity
staying enough there to be able to keep
going up to being able to keeping up the
tree or being very unlikely to get stuck
and that um but
i think trying to
understand that even in this kind of you
know relatively simple model is
is an interesting challenge
yeah so we i mean
the model i even as gould stated it has
multiple walkers but they're not
interacting walkers they're not
competing with one another and that's
that's completely lost in this model
that's somebody
so in the first part of your talk you
had this inequality the number of
generations at least c times the square
root of yeah what's the what does that
really mean does that mean the expected
number of generations is greater than
that or does it mean with high
probability the number of generations
it means both but with different values
of c of course
so
if
if the population is large and
and what you want to do
is
get all of the fractions to be at most
absolute the fractions of bad genes to
be at most epsilon
then you can work out what the c will be
as a function of fecundity and epsilon
okay
um
uh both as an upper bound and a lower
bound so
uh you can get tight bounds if um
uh but
if you have to play one of these end
games then what end game you play what
strategy you use depends upon exactly
what it is that you're trying to
control
and
um
i only did
uh enough work to show
that uh the
contribution of the end game is no
larger than the contribution of the main
term
so the upper bound you get the same form
of upper bound with just with a larger
value of c
yeah it would be very interesting to
contrast this work with winnow
because there
the only thing you would need is that
every genome is above a certain
threshold
the good high is above the threshold you
want to clean it out completely
and put all of the ones that are in the
same chromosome and make
them all identical so
it's very interesting what he did
i mean
and then also to contrast it to the
other regime
yeah but but um
i mean that
um
the last step uh
is is where the population size comes
into it
he has a different goal
and
but for this goal what he does is
optimum
david
yeah uh
there's a lot of work in math
probability on the speed of bias random
walks or trees although they're using a
slightly different model
from what you're you're doing where
instead of fixing a parameter p is a
chance of going to the parent it's sort
of p over
p plus the number of children so they
have a different model out there for a
very expensive work yeah i mean i picked
the model so that i could get pool's
theory as a special case
and and contrast with it um and and
also so that i could get kesten's result
as a special case
one more
yeah so emissions versus omnipotence
yeah your farmer is a very powerful
person yeah
um
suppose all you get to do is design
inhibitors on viral populations and you
can't pick individuals
um well if i have a very smart virus
that can read the genome and take a
threshold function
add and take a threshold function and do
the whole thing
but um um
well i think it is an interesting
um you know if you if you had it
additive contributions and then you did
some hills
thing which wasn't an exact threshold
but but an approximation to it then i
think it would be interesting to see
um
uh how well you could do there there's a
a very interesting result by les valiant
on how you can compute medians or
threshold functions
in the boolean setting if all you can do
is take a majority of three things
or immediately three things
um
and it turns out that you can bootstrap
this very simple
approximate thresholding into a very
exact threshold
so it thinks
things are going fantastically well
because we are
going out of the schedule like crazy
which is fine